kommen wir noch mal kurz zurück zum
medikament rmd sie wir ist das
inzwischen eine normale therapie beide
corona erkrankungen wie sie wissen ist
die substanz relativ schnell zugelassen
worden sie ist hat eine beschränkte
zulassung übrigens auch in europa für
patienten mit sauerstoff wichtigkeit
also schon schwerer erkrankten patienten
über zwölf jahren alt das ist eine
beschränkte zulassung aber sie hat eine
studie ist auch publiziert dazu wir
haben die daten dazu unter contact
gezeigt werden tatsächlich dass die zeit
dauert bis das sich dass patienten
gesunden mit der gabe von randy sie wir
verkürzt werden kann
es kam sogar zu einer absenkung der
sterblichkeit lieber aber in dem
statistischen verfahren wissenschaft
gesehen nicht signifikant aber
erkrankungsdauer wird verkürzen die
patienten genesen schneller und das ist
die grundlage der zulassung für diese
viren ist donald trump ein risikopatient
natürlich ist er ein risikopatient und
das können sie über nachlesen das ist ja
im beitrag vorher von ihrer kollegin
auch schon erwähnt worden klar wenn ein
punkt ganz klar ist ist das alter das
haben wir gelernt den sechs monaten mit
dem wir jetzt mit 19 aka nichts zu tun
haben eine unabhängige und der starts
der risikofaktor erster stationär
aufgenommen zu werden also einen
schweren krankheitsverlauf zu nehmen und
zweitens tatsächlich wenn man einen
schweren krankheitsverlauf nimmt
tatsächlich sterblichkeit drastisch
erhöht im alter zwischen 16 und 74
jahren haben die patienten ein 90 fach
höheres sterblichkeitsrisiko als
patienten zwischen 16 und 29 jahren um
das mal drastisch zu verdeutlichen
das ist aber nur das sterberisiko herr
präsident befindet sich noch nicht in
einer kritischen situation dennoch
bestehen wir erst am anfang der
erkrankung die kritische situation bei
patienten im verlauf einer provinz 19
erkrankungen stellen sich in der regel
erst zwischen tag 7 und tag 12 nach
infektion ein das heißt wir wissen jetzt
circa zwei tagen dass ein positives
testergebnis vorliegt im zeitpunkt der
infektion können wir abschätzen dass wir
jetzt gerade im beginn der krankheit
stehen und perspektiven abzugeben wieder
weiter
auch sein wird sind einfach nur völlig
unpräzise und da möchte ich keine
stellung zu nehmen im moment trump muss
sich also oder muss damit rechnen dass
sich sein zustand verschlechtern könnte
die stadt die wahrscheinlichkeit ist da
es ist auch völlig nachvollziehbar dass
patienten die älter sind die eine ein
älteres immunsystem haben das
immunsystem von eltern patient
funktioniert hat nicht mehr so gut wie
das system eines jüngeren patienten auch
die lungen haben eine höhere
empfindlichkeit für virale aber auch
bakterielle infektionen das ist wohl
bekannt
ich kann nichts über den
allgemeinzustand des präsidenten
aussagen und ich bin der festen
überzeugung er befindet sich in
exzellenter ärzte behandlungen in dieser
klinik dem motto ried hospital
dort stehen alle maßnahmen zur verfügung
der einsatz der monoklonale antikörper
ist ein provisorischer einsatz der unter
medizinern gesichtspunkt sind macht aber
tatsächlich jetzt ein versuch ist die
viruslast bei herrn präsidenten trump
abzumelden damit eventuell auch den
krankheitsverlauf günstig zu
beeinflussen